hi I'm RIA I'm a tasty producer today
I've been challenged to take a common
food and make it fancy the roads are you
must completely use the food given I
hope you guys give me something you can
only up to the food you can buy whatever
ingredients you wish once you begin
cooking you must complete upgraded a
dish in 30 minutes let's see what I have
to make fancy this time
drum roll box mac and cheese actually
I've never had a box mac and cheese
before in order to make it fancy I have
to try it first
can somebody make it for me and can I
try this
it's very suspiciously yellow let me
taste it it's good but I want to make it
better that's Tom Eric Tom Erica is very
funky ingredients so I'm gonna just make
it an Ocoee fancy here's what I got
uncle time Presley shallot garlic and
lobster it's no saw things from pantry
milk sherry [ __ ] blows butter tomato
paste in flour let's get started thank
you so I set up my station in order to
make everything go symmetry I set up
three stones 30 minutes start now first
thing I'm gonna do I'm gonna stop
boiling water I'm going to make bechamel
which is whistles it's la Nova mother
cells in French cuisine two tablespoons
of the butter heat up two cups of milk
and I'm going to cut garlic it's a two
tablespoon of flour so you have to make
sure it's low heat so flour is absorbing
all the fat then you are going to add
heated milk when i tasted mac and cheese
it was very strong flavor so I kind of
want a new try that usually you don't
add garlic for classic bechamel but I
think it's gonna be a good kick to the
thing I'm making right now meanwhile I'm
gonna toss some panko and I'm adding
time so when I was eating the box mac
and cheese it was just like same texture
over and over I wanted to make something
crunchy on top so bechamel looks good
you can test with spatula just run your
finger and this it's done so I'm
toasting panko it's getting nice color
so I think it's ready I'm gonna set it
aside I almost have 20 minutes which is
great
but I'm nervous cause I'm talking and
it's the same time so like I'm gonna
just keep doing stuff I go over started
so lobster it's not as expensive as I
saw we found that she Pat's four dollars
for lobster tail but it's still fancy
right I chose the lobster because it's
cooked super quickly so I'm going to put
in a hot water at soon as I change color
I'm gonna take it out which eats two to
three minutes so love a side cooked I
almost have 16 minutes left I think I
can make it within 30 minutes but I'm
not sure I'm going to cut shallow why
Lobster is cooling down towel
it's milder is an onion so it doesn't
have a sharp flavor so I'm just winging
it I'm making South America but I'm just
like doing some choka I'm going to the
shell right scissors
so you're kind of inserting Caesar it's
inside of the shell break with your hand
it's a little bit sharp so you can you
stall like that well I'm going to and I
just decided to use the water that I
boiled always start with it smells so
good and the lobster shell goes in it
will give a good flavor you are going to
our tomato paste it's gonna be the fun
part I'm gonna flambe flooding it's not
scary at all
just make sure nothing around the
flammable so I'm raising the temperature
of the heat from be funky the reason you
flambe it's just remove this alcohol
flavor if you don't want to do flambe
that's totally fine just high heat bring
it to a boil so alcohol evaporates I
just used sherry but if you don't have
sherry you can use brandy I'm just
winging it so the guy manages our veggie
for us probably like a half cup and then
I'm going to cook macaroni in it
wait so the package said it's cooked
seven to eight minutes and I'm gonna
just do for a minute and see the picture
because I don't want to overcook it I'm
gonna add more vegetables cause it's
already looking a little make sure this
is a little loose white it's going I'm
going to chop lobster just like my sides
let's check the tenderness of the
I'm gonna stop cooking codes on its Oh
then they it's a little hard right now
and Vishal Mel is heating up so I'm
going to all the cheese pocket Wow it's
very yellow how did it achieve it's a
little weird but it's developing very
well I'm going to take off shell which
is super easy cuz like this shell is big
I'm going to add this in here let me
check the flavor it's very nice
a little bit nervous about timing
because I've never made a box mac and
cheese before
[Applause]
to make it whenever stroke and even when
the couch out of the pot okay I'm gonna
keep it going cuz it's okay Oh heavy
just sprinkle some Lobster on top put
some punk on top and I'm gonna just bake
you know then just refresh it because
everything gets cooked I have two
minutes left and I'm gonna just cook it
until timer goes off and I may be I'm
gonna chop some parsley you know like I
have two minutes let's do that so I have
five seconds left so I'm gonna just
sprinkle parsley and me a punch I made
it in 30 minutes it was like a scream
I'm gonna try this and I have a feeling
it's gonna be very decadent and rich and
delicious nice Lobster chunk
[Music]
I make lobster mac and cheese mmm do you
want to try I do
but here's what you have to do a dance
no no I don't make fun alright if I like
it I'll dance about that okay you know
just like when you're venturing around
Italy and you see that like couple
getting like a nice plate of something
or ask the waiter I'll have what they're
having this is like the thing that
they're having that you're like let me
get some - do I make it fancy girl you
know you made it been safe make it easy
there we go
okay so here's my favorite pasty produce
our favorite friend okay wow you made
bucks mac and cheese fancy so you know
how we do make it fuzzy you're going for
seconds thirds take your friends yes
it seems like everyone loves it I
totally encourage you to make at home if
you make it at me on Instagram
show me your fish and show me your dance
make it fancy
this dish is over some song what's kind
of song love semester
mac and cheese mac and cheese we try to
be Beyonce every is gonna get out
[Applause]
[Music]
you